[Musique]
pourquoi nous disons non à votre pass
sanitaire parce qu'il n'a rien de
sanitaires parce que ce pass
autoritaires témoigne de votre échec
c'est une statistique qui figurent dans
le dernier avis du conseil scientifique
en france seuls 62 19 % des personnes
âgées sont vaccinés c'est 100% danemark
100 % en norvège la france et d'après ce
tableau le dernier pays d'europe de
l'ouest pour la vaccination des plus à
risque il faudrait autre chose qu'une
application des vaccinodromes et de la
com il faudrait autre chose qu'un
monarque qui ne sont pas les données
lisez donne des ordres à ses sujets qui
en dix minutes à la télé revient sur ses
promesses de la veille
la vaccination ne sera jamais
obligatoire
le pass and i ter ne s'appliquera pas
aux actes quotidiens à la plage vous
installez le contrôle social tout le
monde qui fliquent tout le monde partout
dans les restos les cafés les centres
commerciaux les signer à la place vous
restreignez les libertés depuis un an
avez vous la moindre stratégie non
[Applaudissements]